safety using Four Paws and a strong nose
the Las Vegas Convention and visitors
Authority adding two new canines on
patrol Victoria Saha explains what their
duties will be during conventions
bear and Reba are the newest addition to
the lvcva's canine unit the more people
visiting our property that you know
would decide well you know we could use
a couple more dogs for assistance
besides being cute and curious these
Labrador retrievers have an important
task during convention season they're
looking mainly for explosives and on
Wednesday their handlers put them to the
test
they needed to find out where there was
a certain scent that was hidden from
them if we didn't have these dogs there
and there was an unattended luggage or
box we would actually have to open it up
and you know take our chances to see
hopefully it's not nothing explosive
inside so we're having these dogs they
could just smell it give us an
indication by sitting besides being on
patrol for conventions that bring in
hundreds of thousands of people the
canines are used for large events such
as the NFL draft last year where one of
their canines picked up on the scent of
an unusual powder we took it like it was
something there and had checked out and
it was just a lot of powder that was
spread out on the ground
so you know it was a good find I thought
a find that's possible only by dedicated
training with big events like Formula
One and Super Bowl coming to Las Vegas
for the very first time the K-9 unit for
lvcva says they're ready for any task
that's given to them to keep everyone
safe Victoria Saha eight news now that
tennis ball doesn't have a chance there
are a total of four dogs on the K-9 unit
Reba and bear will be taken to place of
two older dogs who will be retiring Reba
and bear were bought for a total of
twenty thousand dollars the K-9 units
from all agencies in Las Vegas meet with
lvcva to essentially brainstorm training
techniques for those animals